this afternoon the final game of a
three-game series for the marlins it is
cody poteeta's third major league start
jonathan vr will lead things off again
on 3-2 vr hits a fly ball
shallow left routine for dickerson
he's under it and he has it for the
first out of the day
and a two-out opportunity for dominic
smith
an old one to smith bouncing ball right
into the shift miguel rojas has it about
where the second baseman would normally
be throws onto first and that 6-3 put
out jordan yamamoto making his first met
start and yamamoto with a 3-1
swinging a high-fly ball to center
moving to his right is fargus and
janeshi fargus makes the catch one away
allows a one-out walk here to rojas and
that will bring up the struggling jesus
aguilar
aguilar hits a rope to left right to
maven rojas has to go back to first
jesus aguilar
put a good swing on it but cameron mabin
was standing in the way corey dickerson
will be the batter and the 01 to
dickerson
reaches for a pitch that's down and
golfs it in the air to center fargus
waiting on it makes the one hand catch
and that retires the side neshway fargus
steps to the plate 5 for 17 to start his
major league career
3-2
and that's a called strike 3.
oh one line drive on a couple of bounces
to his left to smother it jazz gets up
goes to first and he got the out nice
play jazz a few steps on the outfield
grass anderson hitting 450 during the
six game hitting streak nine for 20.
fly ball into center field
is this going to get down it will
drops one into right field once again
going the other way a lead-off single
thinks the slider catches it off the end
of the bat
but again look at the eyes right down
the barrel so andy's at second coopers
at first sandy leone stands in you get
this 1-1 pitch that one hit him leon hit
by the pitch and now the bases are
loaded now poteet with one out
a little dribbler up to third yamamoto
throws high
and poteet drives in the run the marlins
lead at one to nothing on what will be
the first big league rbi and what should
be the first major league hit for the
pitcher cody poteet here's jazz base is
loaded one out
and he shoots that one into center field
of base hit gives the marlins a
two-nothing lead with two strikes short
compact to the ball inside out to curve
ball and lines it into center scores a
run it keeps the line moving now the
base is loaded still only one out for
miguel rojas
right side
smith to second for one lindor back to
first it gets away from yamamoto bounces
into the camera well and the marlins are
going to get a break
what a break could have been an inning
ending double play ball
but instead two runs score and miggy
ends up at second base
dom smith the first baseman did the
right thing
got it to lindor
it's always a difficult play yamamoto
got to first base the throw was a pretty
good throw
so the inning goes on
and now the marlins have rojas at second
base aguilar coming up
aguilar center field fargus will play it
on a hop [ __ ] around third he is coming
in to score and jesus aguilar can take a
deep breath
five nothing marlon well a couple of
quality at bats today for aguilar
short compact stroke and with two outs
the smile is back and it's always good
to see to the bottom of the fourth we go
mets trail the marlins five to nothing
and
he golfs this one into center field and
going back for the catch is lindor so
now miguel rojas the marlin shortstop
will step in
pops this one up to the left side of the
infield brandon drury is calling for now
lindor under it and he'll make the catch
for out number two both team back out to
work in the top of the fifth inning a
five-nothing marlins lead all
fargus
pops one up
shallow right near the line it's going
to be chisholm to make the play
brandon drury where the base hit back in
the second inning
105 is fisted into center sierra a
couple of steps back two down
boutique cruising along two quick outs
here in the fifth
there's a swing and a miss by khalil lee
it's another one two three inning for
cody poteet he's cruising along he's
retired eight in a row
cody poteet back on the mound for the
marlins in the top of the six he's
pitching to a five-nothing lead
pop-up shallow right out goes jazz and
the second baseman's got it that's now
nine straight 10 of 11 retired by cody
poteet
one out back to the top order for
jonathan vr
up the middle miggy there spins gets up
throws and gets vr what a play up the
middle miguel rojas
done mickey rowe tremendous defense
once again
hard hit up the middle to the forehand
a little double clutch getting it out of
his glove and a strong throw to aguilar
to finish this one off gratitude from
cody very appreciative of the effort 3-2
swing and a miss he came back and he
struck him out with a good change up
it's been a terrific pitch for him today
for poteet that strikeout number four
through six without allowing a run today
has a five-nothing lead over the match
out there to begin the seventh inning
ground ball backhanded by aguilar hill
lead boutique to the back smith over two
here in the mets seventh one one poteeta
smith bouncing ball again to aguilar he
has it this time he'll wave the pitcher
off takes it himself three and assistant
he wanted that put out baker's dozen 13
in a row retired
maven is in the air to center field
playable for sierra hey boutique does it
again a one two three seven he's retired
14 straight overall curtis two and one
one one to fargus hit on the ground
inside the third base bag a fair ball
headed towards the corner fargus on his
way to second dickerson up with it the
throw coming in his way off line and
fargus is standing at second with his
third two base hit an easy stand up
double for fargus
on 0-1 peraza grounds wide of third to
his left to smother it anderson what a
play he looks the man back throws to
first dug out on the backhand by aguilar
well done
boy the defense continues to dabble
dazzle for brian anderson scrambles up
and while he's doing that after he
picked that ball he had to check the
runner fargus
long drive to left to base it for tobar
janeshway fargus comes home and the
mitts are on the board rbi single in the
eighth inning from will tovar makes it a
five to one game ninth inning anthony
bender
will look to finish this one off two
outs in the ninth marlins leading at
five to one
three two two out pitch maven a swing
and a miss he got him on the slider and
the marlins beat the mets 5-1 to take
this series two games out of three